next on book TVs afterwards Arizona
Senator Jeff Flake discusses his book
conscience of a conservative which calls
for returned to the core principles of
traditional conservatism he's
interviewed by SE Cupp New York Daily
News columnist and host of HLN's cup
unfiltered
let's start with the original conscience
of a conservative written by Brent
Bozell jr. for Barry Goldwater the
original red white and blue book jacket
with the Stars it's it's burned on my
mind it was a guiding text of mine as
conservative and it helped put Goldwater
on a path toward a presidential run are
you trying to tell us something about
your future ambition no no it's very
much a tribute or a homage to Goldwater
you know in 1960 he felt that the
conservative movement and the Republican
Party had been compromised by the New
Deal
and that somebody needed to put together
a blueprint on where the party and the
movement ought to go and that's what the
conscience of conservative was and you
know I think every everybody since then
has looked at that book and that this is
this is it this is the manifesto and so
I I thought that how to honor it that
way because I in a way I think we're
facing some of the same kind of
questions today that the party or the
conservative movement has been
compromised by populist Flair well and
you you begin the book by saying I will
start by saying that I regret having to
write this book I regret it because it's
a necessity as a sign that the American
conservative movement which has been a
force for great good in our country and
to the world is lost why is that
explained well I think I mean Barry
Goldwater defined conservatism is
basically wanting the maximum amount of
freedom consistent with order and then
the principles that animated that or
limited government economic freedom
individual responsibility free trade and
strong American leadership around the
world look at those items think you know
where are we and in terms of limited
government we had a campaign where you
know I would expect the Democratic Party
not to want to touch entitlement
spending but Republicans have always
said no we've we've got to do that
conservatives have to be fiscally
conservative that's that's really the
central tenant but instead we said we're
not going to touch that and we'll leave
that to future generations I guess or
other
champagnes and then with regard to you
know building the party and playing a
game of addition rather than subtraction
I think we went the other way kind of
drilled down on some really you know
that on the base and with regard to free
trade for example we are only five
percent of the world's population we're
less than twenty five percent of the
world's economic output if we don't find
new markets for our good if we don't
recognize this this economy that has
globalized around us with us we can
either be part of it and take advantage
of it and harness it or we can be left
behind by it
and I'm afraid that we're gonna be left
behind by it well and I want to I want
to get to free trade and some of the
specifics that you lay out but still
more broadly you know we have a
Republican in the White House Republican
control of Congress
we've got Republicans the majority of
state houses explain to someone how
conservatism is lost
right well I remember very well when we
were in this position just a few years
ago I got to Congress in 2001 I ran a
conservative think-tank in the 1990s the
Goldwater Institute Mike Pence was
running the Indiana policy review we
were we knew each other then we were
elected together and you know during the
1990s the party was really animated by
ideas
I still remember and I talked about in
the book bill Archer the chairman of the
Ways and Means Committee and and Dick
Armey who was then later the majority
leader they had a book tour but they
went around the kind of kind of like a
book tour but they they promoted it like
a concert tour right where they were
debating the merits of the flat tax
versus the consumption tax you know I
kept it as a reminder of when the party
stood for principle and actually argued
principle but I remember sitting on the
the floor at one point with with mike
pence and he said you know sometimes and
after we were presented with the
Presidents Bill No Child Left Behind
which you know for conservatives I think
tank conservatives that was federal
intrusion into local education and that
was an alma to conservatives and Mike
said you know I feel sometimes like
we're Minutemen called up to the
Battlefront only to be told the
revolution is over so there we were and
then we had to vote on a prescription
drug benefit which added about seven
trillion dollars in unfunded liabilities
didn't think that was very conservative
and then Republicans engaged in just
horrible types of spending as well the
earmarking era was fully underway 2001
to 2006 and we really lost our way and
because we couldn't claim that we were
fiscally conservative anymore I mean
that was thrown out the window with all
the spending then we had to argue about
things like flag-burning you know and
then delve into the wedge issues and and
I I think in some ways we've we've never
gotten back we had the majority in the
House in the Senate and we had the White
House and we lost it
2006 we lost the house in the Senate and
then 2008 lost the White House so just
because we have those majorities today
doesn't mean that we'll have them even
two years from now or a year and a half
from them well I liked the the anecdote
of you and Mike Pence as freshmen or
running around a retreat sounding like
Rainman taking tax cuts definitely
thanks good that's great you know I
found a lot of voters and in particular
Trump voters who think that these
academic arguments about the health of
conservatism are uninteresting and
really the concerns of privileged elites
how do you make the case rightly I think
that the health of conservatism is an
urgent matter that actually has real
real-world implications well I think I
guess you can split two things you can
win elections and if you're doing that
just for the sake of winning elections
then yeah we can do that but if we as
conservatives want to enact conservative
policy then
you have to treat an election like how
do we set this up for governing and ways
that we can move forward with our agenda
and if you take one of the items that
was you know big during this last
election you know the president very
effectively realized the concerns of
people you know in a transitioning
economy those in the Rust Belt in
particular it's very easy for a
politician as I write in the book to
point to a shuttered factory and say
it's because the Chinese took your job
or the Mexicans took your job it was
easy and it works and it does I'm not
denying the yeah the popularity of
populism that's it's called populism
for a reason but and and if you just
want to win elections I guess you can
you can win one here there but people
expect you to govern and particularly as
a conservative you want to enact
conservative policy and and so I mean it
would have been better to say yes there
you know it's it's tougher it's you know
anything beyond 30 seconds they say if
you're talking that long you're losing
but but you have to recognize that a
factory is shuttered probably because of
automation and productivity gains we
manufacture twice what we did in the
1980s with one-third fewer workers there
are dislocations we have to recognize
that and more effectively prepare people
for the workforce of the future but that
doesn't mean that we can just tell them
you know hey if we knock out this trade
deal then you're gonna be winning again
it's harder to explain an effete or at a
rally in a campaign slogan it is and I
think the whole tweeting culture you
know from all of us said you know you
can't reduce complex policy problems 240
characters and it is difficult but but I
think it's a responsibility of
conservatives first and foremost to have
some honesty at least and say you know
hey if you have a factory job in an auto
factory yeah you know you may be
transitioning out of it this economy is
going to change it will be disruptive
that's why we've got to have a situation
where you can
prepare for the future but not tell them
hey you know we're gonna get your jobs
back these coal jobs are all coming back
right you know it just is not honest
well and you talk about that great dick
armey bill archer tour we didn't hear a
lot of those debates over ideas during
the election is can can big ideas still
win hearts and minds in this class I
think that I think I hope it makes a
comeback I think when voters start to
value actually not just an election win
but but progress toward enacting
conservative goals and and I have to say
as a conservative you know this
president he nominated Neel Gorsuch to
the Supreme Court it was a big deal for
conservatives a big deal for me
I was very pleased to help Shepherd his
his nomination through the Judiciary
Committee and then on the floor that's a
great win that we'll have conservative
implications I think in the future and
another nominations to the federal bench
and other cabinet appointments you know
that's the start of good conservative
policy if we can follow through now but
but part of my concern
revolves around not just being
conservative in terms of policy but
being conservative in terms of demeanor
and comportment and manners and and in
foreign policy a conservative needs to
be steady and needs to be sober and
predictable and respect our institutions
and those international institutions
that have served as well for so long and
and that anything else is not
conservative
well sticking to domestic policy for now
that obsession you had with tax cuts
right as a freshman I mean it's why I
became a conservative or fiscal policy
can tax cuts and starve the beast fiscal
conservatism can that still appeal can
that break through it doesn't feel sexy
enough right no no not when you put it
like that let me get a reaction at a
think-tank no I got that
but not out
but but I think what it is is people
understand you talk to small businesses
out there large corporations out there
they'll tell you the same thing we have
to have we were competing globally now
more than ever and we have to have a
conducive tax and regulatory environment
and we don't have that right now with
regard to corporate taxes where I'm
Hmong the highest in the world on
regulatory policy we were getting way
way out of whack there and I do think
that the president has pushed back and
and I think the the reaction and the
fact that we had 2.6 percent economic
growth when that eclipses anything we've
had recently that's in large measure due
to people assuming that we're going to
move forward on tax policy and have
regulatory policy that's conducive so I
think that that that's important if you
explain it to people like that if we
lower regulations I think small business
people in particular understand that
well but boy whether it's health care
regulation financial regulation
environmental regulation labor
regulation it's been all-consuming you
tell a very moving story about how to
immigrants from muslim-majority
countries save the life of your
father-in-law and then you also a little
later talk about how anti-mormon bigotry
drove your family flakes to to Arizona
talk about Trump's Muslim ban with those
two experiences as a backdrop well when
when the president in December of 2015
announced he would have a Muslim band it
was put forward as a Muslim ban that to
me and I think to the heart of any
Mormon just you know that that's a
dagger like a Norman ban I mean people
who may not know the history in the
1840s there was an extermination order
in the state of Missouri for Mormons
basically fair game go Adam and and that
was stayed on the books until late 1975
by the way certainly I wasn't
wasn't utilized that much beyond the
1840s but the Mormons were driven there
to Illinois and then ultimately across
the the plains to Utah and my
great-great great-grandfather was among
that group but so that that was kind of
fresh in our minds and when you say you
know there's a Muslim ban there might as
well be a Mormon man more a Mexican ban
it just doesn't sit right and so when
that was announced I took my family and
we went to a mosque and I went to daily
prayers just to to you know say that we
didn't disagree or didn't agree with
that and that that wasn't a traditional
Republican position
it was later modified to be a travel ban
and I would argue the latest iteration
is constitutional part of it has been
upheld part of it hasn't so it's not the
constitutional aspect a Muslim man is
clearly unconstitutional but the way it
came out isn't I just didn't think it
was very wise I believe that if we're
gonna win this war on terrorism this war
against radical Islam we have to
recognize that and not ascribe radical
Islamic views to every Muslim and and
that's kind of what a Muslim ban
certainly does and this travel band I
explained in the book how that came
about and the the the six countries that
ultimately ended up there
people tended to think well that was
President Obama's list and that was a
tried and true and and and a list that
was deliberated on it really wasn't I
talk in the book about how that came
about if we are going to have a ban
that's based on geography or by country
at least have some deliberative process
where you choose those countries and we
didn't go through that here but I
explained in the book my great Maya my
father-in-law had kind of a heart attack
or a ruptured aorta last November and
rushed to the hospital and ultimately
11-hour surgery the first surgeon fought
ecori saved his life and
but then his heart just wouldn't start
and so they had to bring in a new and
it's called an ECMO machine that would
circulate the blood and keep his heart
going or the other organs going while
the heart recovered and the the man that
that did that was from the Mayo Clinic
by the name of John Raja Han yer Fadi
quarry was raised he was a Palestinian I
believe raised in Lebanon and Johan Yura
was raised in Afghan in Afghanistan and
and if we had these type of bands of
people from majority Muslim countries
then we would lose out on a lot of the
talent it in the medical field or in
high-tech or anything else that we rely
on and that in this case very much saved
my father-in-law's life did it bother
you that the sound of this Muslim ban
actually appealed to a lot of people yes
it did and I know I'm not not
discounting the popularity of it and and
I certainly not blaming the voters of
the population because partly because
politicians often will exaggerate that
threat or paint with it a broad brush
that that is intended to rile people up
and so I I don't blame those ultimately
who who have the that sentiment as much
as I blame those of us in a position to
do otherwise who don't well Goldwater's
book was also controversial mainly
because of its stance on the civil
rights act at the time these are trying
times in America for for racial divide
what role do you think conservatives
need to play in bridging that racial
divide well I think one that really
touches on the racial divide is
immigration immigration reform and I do
think that the Republicans need to be
the party that welcomes immigrants and
I've mentioned I can remember if they
ended up in the in the book or not but I
talked about when
about Tim Kaine was chosen by Hillary
Clinton as her running mate his first
speech was in Florida and he spoke often
in Spanish in that speech where he spoke
Mary very movingly of a naturalization
ceremony that he had attended or others
that he had attended and and I just
thought at that time that should be us
that used to be us
that's what the Republican Party where
we celebrated those who have made it
here and wanted by choice to be an
American and and I thought were giving
that up and and it really hurt during
this campaign if we look into the future
you know after the 2012 election
Republicans we sat down and did the
famous autopsy and which concluded we've
got to appeal to a broader audience and
when you look at that audience George W
Bush won in 2000 and in 2000 getting 56
percent of the white vote Mitt Romney
lost in 2012 getting 59% of the white so
every two years the electorate is about
two percent less white and and if we
don't have a message that is appealing
to everyone if we have a message that
some groups feel that they are being
targeted or left behind or left out then
we aren't going to be successful
electoral II and and I would submit that
it's it's not a conservative message to
not have a message that appeals to
everyone and and and feel that we can
include everyone I want to move to a
subject that's very important to me fake
news Democratic anti-democratic regime
do we allow alternate facts to compete
with the truth
president Trump seems pretty bent on
undermining the truth and the belief
that a strong Free Press is one of the
best mechanisms
at getting at the truth how do
conservatives and citizens combat that
well I devote an entire chapter in the
book on that because it is so important
and and I say in there you know we have
a First Amendment gratefully ha that
protects the freedom of the press
freedom information and we ought to
cherish that and hold to it all we can
there's been some talk in other
governments and in Europe democratic
governments of putting severe limits or
big fines for what would later be
determined fake news that doesn't work
here and shouldn't work here so you hope
that there's some kind of market
response right that people in the end
will value real news over fake news but
it is really concerning when you when
you look at you know I talk in that
chapter a lot about you know this canard
and old conspiracy theory about Barack
Obama and where he was born that there
were a lot of us who came out and said
from the beginning don't traffic in
nonsense like that don't don't do it
don't go there but I think too many
conservatives were silent or or engaged
in that and that that is very hurtful
not just to those who were involved or
we're targeted by that but by the entire
process we democracy depends on some
shared facts some truths that are
self-evident and and if we don't have
that we're in real trouble I was really
concerned the other day to see a poll
that said 49% of Republicans believe
that Donald Trump won the popular vote
and now Donald Trump won the electoral
college that's all that's important
that's who and what has made him our
legitimate president but he didn't win
the popular vote that is a truth that
should be self-evident but because of
you know news sources pushing things out
that that that are not right too many
people are believing it and it is a big
problem we haven't found
the solution to it I hope it's a market
kind of solution where people will value
real news but it's going to be a problem
for a long time well in particular
because the primary trafficker of that
birther conspiracy was Donald Trump now
profited on that is our president so
there's not a lot of lessons about not
trafficking in fake news or conspiracy
theories to point to to say here's where
it will get you well it got you to the
White House though that's I'm glad that
he he dropped it I'm glad that he did
and but I do think it's incumbent on
elected officials to when things that
are just so demonstrably untrue that
will not countenance I just say I'm
sorry we can't go there I want to go to
free trade you talk about the 2016
election and all the conservative
positions on trade and a global economy
that to quote you we seemingly overnight
abandoned in favor of quote
back-of-the-envelope populist slogans
but as we talked about earlier those
slogans really resonated with a lot of
Americans did voters when it comes to
free trade did voters reject your
version of conservatism well I think in
this case I mean if you're given two
choices
something easy or something hard an easy
answer or a hard truth it's you know
it's more attractive to take the easy
choice particularly when you're
entertained in the process and this was
an entertaining election but that
doesn't absolve us of you know
recognizing we've got to tell the truth
and the truth is you know when there is
a shuttered factory it's more complex
than China took those jobs and and so I
what I am concerned about is when we
come off this sugar high of populism
what happens in what happens when those
coal jobs don't return
they say in Arizona for example we have
a coal plant in northern Arizona it's
called the Navajo Generating Station for
years we've been trying to keep it open
protecting it against onerous
regulations environmental regulations
that were threatening it's closed and it
just couldn't make it cost-effective
given the regulations but then it's we
got to - now when maybe some of those
regulations might be right-sized or more
more appropriate but then the market
changed completely and natural gas is so
cheap that overnight that was simply not
economically viable and for the future
you couldn't impose that on ratepayers
and so it's closing down but you know it
would be easier to say no we're gonna
it's it's regulation that's keeping this
you know or stopping us from keeping
this this plant going but in truth now
it's the market and that's the case with
a lot of manufacturing like I say we're
doing a lot more of it we're just doing
it more efficiently and and requiring
fewer workers but those are hard truths
that we're going to have to either you
know talk about now or talk about later
and and I what I fear is that if we win
elections based on talking about the
easy things then it's a particularly
hard fall later on and so we might as
well just tell the truth
you talk about vote no hope yes politics
and the dangers of that and you wrote
that maintaining one's ideological
purity for political reasons is neither
principled nor conservative first
explain what you mean by that
well I talked about in the house and I
gave one particular example of where I
felt that I hoped yes and voted no when
we had the big bailout the tarp the
Troubled Assets that was an awful thing
and I felt fully justified you know
voting against that I hadn't voted you
know in terms of regulations relieving
those regulations or whatever else that
may have caused this I didn't vote for
spending that
may have led to it and so I felt hey I
can just vote no and I did voting
against bailouts is what we do right
exactly and and I did and then that the
stock market dropped I think what was it
7% in just a few hours after the house
did and I and I thought at the time you
know I've still not going to vote for
this
I'll let but but but at that time
believe me I was believing what Hank
Paulson and Ben Bernanke were saying
that I think one memorable line I quote
in the book you know somebody asks what
happens on on Monday if we don't do this
he said if we don't do this we won't
have an economy and it was particularly
stark and so I I believed it at that
point but I relied on other people my
colleagues to provide the votes to get
over the top so I could protect my
sterling you know voting record against
all that kind of spending and and I
regretted that later because I thought
I'm I just let somebody else carry my
water I still you know bailed I would
have been justified already know I
hadn't caused it but as a Roy Blunt but
it memorable he was a member of
leadership in the house at that time he
told that I fell in the book of the old
story and colonial India where they
built the the British built these golf
courses and the monkeys kept coming and
taking the balls and they couldn't
decayed the monkeys off of the course so
they developed a rule that you you
played the ball where the monkey throws
and and so that's what he said at the
time you know we may not have caused
this but we've got to play the ball
where it was thrown and and and I think
other people did that and I didn't
wonder what you think about the
Democratic Party right now is going
through a similar struggle of purity
versus pragmatism when it comes to the
issue of abortion and some prominent
Democrats have said we're not going to
fund Democratic candidates who happen to
be pro-life what do you think about that
kind of existential crisis that they're
having well I think
we kind of have it on both sides but
they're certainly having it there and
yeah it's I mean if you have a party
that can be a party that wins election
and governs it's tough to be you know
pure on everything and use every issue
as a litmus test and certainly the
Republican Party is I hope you know we
can provide a big tent we have to if
we're going to survive in the future not
that we don't fight for every principle
but we have to assume that not everyone
has the same constituency or has exactly
the same beliefs so there's always a
trade Barry Goldwater himself said at
one point
this isn't quoted as much as his
convention speech but he said something
like politics is nothing more than
public business sometimes you make the
best of a mixed bargain and and and so
even the most principled to the people
that we look to recognize that you
sometimes have to compromise to get you
know going in the right direction and I
think certainly and we're finding that
on health care it would have been nice
to be able to do it exactly in the image
that we wanted to but that's not where
we are I think some might argue that
that sounds like a defensive Trump who
is not an ideological purist by any
means someone who makes decisions based
on the situation without real you know
political philosophy behind it do you
see do you see that as maybe some some
good in him no I mean I there there is
when you're you have a president and or
a leader of a party there are obviously
times when you swallow hard and and you
don't accept things that you don't want
to but I think you have to have some
core principles that that drive at least
or your instincts and you have to be
moving in the right direction and
however you feel on the policy side you
have to recognize that being a
conservative means that your
and what even-tempered and temperate and
and and have manners and you don't refer
to your political opponents in ways that
make it difficult to work with them in
the future so a lot of it is back to
demeanor and comportment well I'm glad
you brought that up because to a person
anyone you ask in this town Washington
what they think of Jeff Flake they will
say that you're one of the nicest people
on the hill and I can't disagree you
famously modeled bipartisanship by
marooning yourself on a desert island
with a friend of mine Martin Heinrich a
Democratic senator but Trump mocked our
cries for civility over the course of
the campaign and he said look we've got
too many big problems to worry about
tone the tone in our politics why is he
wrong I think he's wrong because in the
end particularly in the Senate when it
requires 60 votes do just about anything
you if you don't get along with your
colleagues you don't that you achieve
any ends let alone conservative ends
there are severe limits on what you can
do under rules of reconciliation we
found those we've discovered those and
so I I just I think that there's never
never a bad time to to be good and I
mentioned one of the chapters of about
my own upbringing and watching models
you know a behavior in my own life and
people in elected official and in
elected positions I grew up in snowflake
small town my father served as mayor and
he served on boards and commissions and
was involved in public service my uncle
Jake flake from snowflake
the Speaker of the House in Arizona well
beloved by both sides he teamed up with
Jack brown a Democrat from st. John's
and where the Udall family comes from
mostly Democrats but they they modeled
havior and I think as a rural lawmaker
you have to do that and when you grow up
on a ranch as I did and watch my
brothers or my son or my father and his
brothers around the ranch my seven
brothers and four sisters said you you
gotta have to get along and and there's
no if you don't do the work nobody does
it and I think that that's how you know
City Council's work all over the country
that's how state legislators usually
have to work because they can't borrow
money and you know put off decisions
that they they should have to make now
we just haven't been able to do it here
and so I think we we can get away
sometimes in Congress or we shouldn't
but we do get away with behavior that
wouldn't be tolerated at any other level
of government but because we can just
paper over our differences by spending
more money and by having a bigger
deficit and putting off decisions that
we should be making now it's just it's
not not the example that I grew up with
and my parents I always mentioned my
mother on our fridge she had for as long
as I can remember the the phrase assumed
the girth I assumed the best look for
the good okay and and that's you know I
think that that's a good good credo for
any politician when you're looking at
the other side you know assume the best
and look for the good well when these
these existential crises can bring some
unexpected allegiances can conservatives
and liberals find some common causes
right now and if so what should they do
well the big one that we need to come
together on is our looming debt and our
massive deficit
it's a deficit is about six hundred
billion now it'll be over a trillion in
a couple of years according to CBO that
will be added to our twenty trillion
debt every year at some point the
markets are going to respond not in a
good way and say we're not no longer a
good bet and then we become my Greece or
like Japan or other countries that just
will be digging out for you know decades
if not generations
I don't want to get to that point but in
order to to get there if you look at it
every good budget agreement we've had
over the past 40 years it's been when
we've had divided government when
Republicans and Democrats sat down and
said all right let's share the political
risk let's both tout this deal that's
given enough in each party to go along
with this that was you know Reagan and
Tip O'Neill
it was gramm-rudman-hollings it was a
budget deal of 97 you name it if that's
what happened and it's gonna have to
happen now it's far more difficult when
one party controls both chambers in the
White House because that party never
wants to to deal with entitlement
spending because the other party if they
don't help then the party that doesn't
bears the whole blame you know in the
next elections and with that that's the
issue where we've got to come together
we've got to sit down and say let's
share the political risk well lastly
talk about the future of conservatism
you know under President Trump a lot of
people are wondering what what's next
where we go what does my generation of
conservatives and then millennial
generation of conservatives where do we
take where do we take the movement where
do we take the party I do and I think
that the the principles that are
outlined in the book that Goldwater
outlined you know limited government
economic freedom individual
responsibility those are the principles
that vana made the animated the party
for so long and and really are I think
kind of was the founding vision that our
founding fathers had and they've served
us well and can serve us well long is it
the future now it will take different
forms you know given the age that we're
in technology and globalization
you know it's configured a little
differently but those principles are
timeless and I think the future is
bright for conservatism if we can you
know stick to those principles and
behave well while we do and and not
assume the worst motives to our
political opponents and I I think the
future's bright when you look at what
we've gone through and my first day in
the Senate
they took us all the newly elected
senators to the National Cathedral
another another Cathedral to the
archives and we viewed all the founding
documents and then went to the
legislative vault and saw the you know
the oaths of Allegiance signed by
Revolutionary War soldiers witnessed by
General Washington and it was just an
incredible evening but what a thing I
came away with was we have come through
some really serious things Civil War you
know and women's right to vote civil
rights struggles and we've gotten
through them and we can get through some
big things these challenges we have
today I don't think are as serious as
those so if we come together and work in
good faith we can get through it and I
think with conservative principles
leading the way good to hear
thank you thank you